[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen meint orten
welt heute gibt es mal einen ganz
schnellen blechkuchen und zwar mache ich
einen leckeren saftigen kokos kuchen mit
buttermilch und zwar haben wir den vor
kurzem auf dem kindergarten flohmarkt
gegessen und dann habe ich ganz schnell
haben rezept gesucht habe es gefunden
und hab es jetzt ein bisschen
abgewandelt weil mir war da ein bisschen
zu süßem radfahren den eigentlich
perfekt aber ich noch jetzt trotzdem
lieber bisserl die zuckerreduzierte
variante und zeigt euch einfach mal kurz
an alle zutaten
ich brauche drei eier dann wird das
ganze in bechern gerechnet auch auf
meinem blog werde ich euch die genaue
gramm angaben hinschreiben ich brauche
eine halb affen zucker 2000 buttermilch
vier tassen mehl und eineinhalb päckchen
backpulver und dann brauche ich für den
belag noch 2000 kokosraspeln ich hier
noch eine halbe tasse zucker etwas
vanille extrakt und später zu übergießen
nehmen wir einfach noch 200 gramm fahne
das ist ein ganz normaler becher warum
es soll im becken
ich denke dass es ursprünglich entweder
ein amerikanisches rezepte oder einfach
wegen der einfachheit das motto halt
keinen thermometer wolfach keine waage
braucht sondern einfach in bechern das
rechnen kann also ein becher hat jetzt
bei mir 250 milliliter fassungsvermögen
und so könnt ihr euch dann praktisch
abmessen bin jetzt und becher gehabt
einfach in bechern aus messen
weil idioten sind auch so seine tücken
ist auch so ist halt einfach aber ich
finds halt um genauer und deswegen
schreibe ich immer gerne die
mengenangaben gramm hin und ist für mich
eben einfacher
jetzt gebe ich die eier in eine
rührschüssel und gebt den zucker auch
direkt mit dazu
und ich gebe auch ein bisschen vanille
mit in den teig also kommt es hier mit
ein paar tropfen vor allem wenn man das
ganz frisch auf macht so wie ich jetzt
dann hat man das ganze vanillemark da
oben
da braucht mir echt nur zwei drei
tropfen davon und jetzt lasse ich das
schön cremig früheren ähnlichen chance
[Musik]
und so reicht es auch schon also das war
nicht gerade ein paar sekunden so
vielleicht mehr minute und jetzt gebe
ich die buttermilch mit rein und ihr
seht auch in dem teig kommt ansonsten
gar kein fett mit rein also der teig ist
ziemlich fett arm gut später die sahne
die macht es dann wieder bisschen fertig
aber wenn man sie zu allgemein sieht
also ist das ein ziemlich fettarme aber
zuckerreiche kuchen und das rede ich
jetzt auch noch kurz
und für alle geht das so einfach das
kann nicht jeder nachbar sogar so war
der bogert samira kann das so mit hänger
aber der morath halt jetzt vermisse ich
hier ganz kurz backpulver mit dem mehl
damit nicht so klumpp dem teig und sich
schön verteilt hatte ich sage mir hat
jedes bestimmt auch gerne mitgemacht
aber die schon morgens im kindergarten
und jetzt gebe mal das mehl mit dem
backpulver hier rein und es wirkt bei
ganz niedriger stufe noch ganz kurz
verrührt und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich hier schon mal ein backblech
vorbereiten und heute nehme ich ein ganz
normales standard backblech wenig später
noch mit der sana übergießen will hat
nicht dass irgendwo was ausläuft dank
jetzt einfach ein bisschen wasser rein
gegeben und geht jetzt meinen fragt ob
ihr drüber damit das backpapier eben
auch schön am boden lebt und zehn mal
wieder hoch springt man könnte es auch
fetten aber durch zauber machen halt
einfach kurz die geschwindigkeit hoch
dass es besser verrührt
und ich finde nur drei gelbe welche
buttermilch werden immer extrem saftig
und ich habe da schon mal buttermilch
themes gemacht und die waren auch so
richtig locker und saftig also echt
lecker aber wenn ihr die nicht habt
könnt ihr jetzt auch milch nehmen wobei
ich euch echt empfehlen wird es möglich
muttermilch zu machen kann schon leuten
die spätschicht habe nicht das tägliche
arbeiten morgens war ja monate später ja
ich arbeite schwer erarbeitete schwer
von morgens bis abends die heute nur
abends wie sowas ist für mich jetzt auch
arbeit
ach so ja natürlich natürlich habe ich
meine erste kamera halten tonassistent
machen
so ist verteilung und den teig hier auf
dem backblech die schwere schüssel und
einfach meint aber das ist so ein
ratzfatz rezept lautet das rezept genau
[Musik]
so und jetzt nehme ich hier gerade die
kokosraspeln und gibt die hier in meine
mail schlüssel damit jetzt keine andere
schüssel macht dafür braucht und gebt
dem zucker mit dazu originalrezept war
das eine tasse zucker als ihr könnt
entscheiden ob eine tasse oder eine
halbe tasse nimmt ich finde eine halb
das erreicht auch schon und jetzt noch
bisschen vanille kind mit vanillezucker
nehmt group will großzügige sind das
vermisse ich jetzt gucke auch dass sich
die vanille schön auflöst foto schön
verteilt kommt es mal mit den händen
es geht schneller
das vanille ex packt es kommen ja auch
selber machen ja das kann ich auch
selber machen
nun muss dann halt in alkohol machen
also da musste vanilleschote nehmen
aufschneiden mag aus katzen und alles in
alkohol einlegen und so drei vier monate
stehen lassen dann hat es richtig gut
durchgezogen aber da ja nicht wie nicht
jeder vanille extrakt mit alkohol will
nehme ich halt immer das fertige vanille
aroma oder vanille extrakt weil es halt
in fett eingelegt und alkoholfrei ist
also das ist der große vorteil vor allem
wenn halt mit kindern wagt oder muslime
oder hat jede darf alkohol verzichten
deswegen habe ich das halt immer so
macht statt netz selber platz laura
jetzt hier aber jetzt kann ich hier das
schön verteilen und vanille und kokos in
verbindung nicht halt echt super lecker
das ist auch noch machen könnte es wäre
echt toll aber ich weiß was funktioniert
ich bin vanille kokos und mandarine
finde ich klasse
ja wobei es auf dem blechkuchen geht es
jetzt glaube ich nicht so gut
ich werde es wahrscheinlich meine
eigenen wachsen noch mal machen kann
jetzt einfach ein bisschen verteilen
ein bisschen streiche
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich den kuchen bei 190
grad im vorgeheizten backofen ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr 25 minuten in
den backofen ich werde auf jeden fall
mit zahnstocher die stäbchen probe
machen der zwischenzeit stelle ich schon
meine sahne wieder kühl denn die muss
schön kalt sein
und dann beginnen wir gleich dennoch
ganz heißen kuchen mit der ganz kalten
zahlen
ich mache aber gleich zusammen
[Musik]
hier ist meine ganz heißer kuchen und
ich zeige euch mal die stäbchen probe
und zwar stehe ich da mit zahnstocher
rhein wo wir nichts mehr daran klebt
dann ist ruhig und ich mache das halt
oft und verschiedener stelle weil meine
drei ist auf der backofen gleichmäßig
backt oder nicht
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die ganz kalte sahne und
gießt sie hier
über den ganzen kuchen und er sorgt
dafür dass da jetzt gleich richtig
richtig sein schrieb ein user brandt
zwieback soko wismar stimmt ich denke
ganz einfach was riecht es stimmt dass
richtige zwieback mit kokos
[Musik]
zudem muss man sorgfältig
ich glaub schon jetzt nach hause fahren
weil ich finde das reicht nicht so ganz
obwohl ich mir jetzt noch besser fahren
und so las ich jetzt einfach den kuchen
komplett abkühlt und dann dürfen wegen
gleich probieren und nicht träume ich
schon mein kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich irgendwie schneiden
ich mache jetzt bisschen größere stücke
mal dass ich jetzt keinen so sehr hoher
kuchen war so ganz normale stücke und
ich merke auch jetzt schon wie schön
weiter ist
[Musik]
das wird daher nicht ganz gesund
was soll das jetzt kein scharfes messer
geld es ist schon ein bisschen scharf
aber jetzt nicht so scharf dass es
meinem backpapier zerschneide wird das
schon 2 1 1 ging also ich kann doch mit
dem kuchen hebe und auch schneide das
erste stück geht immer bisschen
schwierig aus und so steht jetzt der
kuchen von innen aus also unten der
saftige teig und dann eben diese artikel
kokos schicht und in der mitte ist sie
jetzt feucht und oben ist so schön
knusprig also ich denke der schmeckt
genauso wie er ausgeht der morath darf
darauf gespannt hat sich mit weniger
zucker kennnummer aber ich glaub vom
zuckergehalt her dürfte trotzdem genug
sein mag ist super ja und ganz ehrlich
wird nicht mehr zu nehmen
genau ich würde mich also ich habe
insgesamt zwei gläser zucker weggelassen
also ein glas zukommt 250 pro jahr 200
bis 250 gramm zugab ich weggelassen und
ich finde zu stroh schon genug kann die
absolut also ich hätte mit wenigen
jahren ist weniger besitzen brot aber
auch mehr wirklich okay dann stehe ich
bin jetzt auch gleich mal ein foto für
instagram und facebook und ihr dürft das
rezept gerne nachbacken dass ich
wirklich ein super einfaches
superschnelles rezept also vom
zubereiten des tages bis zum ende der
backzeit sind es vielleicht 25 minuten
und da müsse es eben noch mal kurz
abkühlen lassen und habe dann ein
schneller kuchen und ihr dürft gerne
auch sehr lesen blog de nachlesen und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder distanzschuss
[Musik]